newspapers flyers and Diaries
in these boxes and insight into the
relatively Untold History of being black
and LGBT in Britain so the archive goes
back to 1976 over a thousand items
including lesbian fanzines a lot of
writing by black lesbians t-shirts for
more adult Gatherings black steam was
like a party event that was took place
in the sauna and Community made and run
Publications probably the first
commercial magazine created by black
lgbtq people the Ruckus black LGBT
cultural archive is a first for the
London Metropolitan archives an attempt
to record stories that have been
historically erased when we were younger
back in the 90s most of the time people
questioned whether we existed as black
lgbtq people because
a lot of the black community denied our
existence a lot of the white mainstream
lgbtq Community denial existence
deposited in 2010 by topha and
photographer WX The Collection contrasts
with some of the earlier items held on
site for the London Metropolitan archive
collections like Ruckus show just how
much it's changed over time focusing not
just on institutions but also on
personalized stories too and with over a
thousand years worth of History right
here in this building it's collections
like this from the public morality
Council that show just how broad The
Collection is so these are uh two boxes
from the public morazi Council
collection they were keeping track of
the fences that they could report on
active from the end of the 19th century
through to the late 1960s the public
morality Council monitored prostitution
Cinema and what they saw was the evil of
hypersexuality and homosexuality on
wider Society you can compare that in
quite an interesting way against
collections like Topher energies and you
can see today that we were able to
record people's personal experiences in
a very different way lots of stuff a new
approach that we're records a previously
overlooked part of society in a way that
is undeniable black history and black
lgbtq history are one and the same we're
right in the middle of that history now
a permanent part of a thousand years of
History the Ruckus archive tells a
unique Story by recording how a
community partied how it found love and
how it refused to be marginalized Jason
manta ray Sky News